ladies and gentlemen i hate to be the
bearer of bear news but this might be
the scariest
chart you'll ever see and i'll explain
why welcome back to the 10 million
dollar studio boys i'm your host coffee
zilla and today we're talking once again
about tether if you haven't seen sort of
the big summary video of what the whole
uh situation is with them we'll link it
below tether is one of the biggest sorry
it is the biggest stable coin one of the
main ways crypto markets get liquidity
and if you're excited about how the
crypto markets are just going straight
up you might want to see this for a
second here now as we know a lot of
people have suspected for a long time
that tether is not
backed by you know really anything
people have said it's not backed by us
dollars eventually they admitted that
was true it's backed by a basket of
receivables mostly commercial paper we
have come to find out but i want to show
you their market cap just to illustrate
something this is what i think is a
pretty scary chart if you're heavily
invested in crypto and guys again i'm
not saying this isn't to make you panic
it's not to make you go sell everything
it's to educate you some people are
going to tell you be bullish at all
times you know just be a bull don't ever
think about anything like this some
people are going to tell you that the
sky's falling look i don't really
subscribe to either of those i do invest
a little bit in crypto
i don't talk about what i'm investing
because i don't want to steer you guys
towards my stupid way of thinking but my
point is i'm not just some some blind
hater but at the same time you guys have
to be educated with what your what your
risks are and right now not a lot of
people are talking about this
so this chart is tethers market cap
basically because tether is worth a
dollar whatever their market cap is is
how many tethers are in existence
actually it's pretty easy way to track
how much they've been printing and
people call tether sort of the central
bank of crypto because they seem like
they can just print whenever they want
now
if you guys remember the new york
attorney general investigated them and
found that tether lied when they said
that they were always backed one to one
and that from 2017 to like late 2018
like november-ish they were unbacked
right and then in 2019 they changed
their disclosure to say yeah we're
actually not backed one to one we've
been lying to you guys pretty much for
our entire existence uh but don't pay
attention to that but what i want to try
your attention to do guys is okay so
this chart that i have in front of me is
tether's market cap during the time that
the new york attorney general says they
were unbacked right the new york
attorney general says for sure we know
at this point they were lying to people
we know that they were not telling the
truth okay so look at this chart and i'm
gonna slowly take it so this is the end
of 2018 beginning 2019 here this is when
they change their disclosure what i'm
going to do is i'm going to slide this
over and you're going to see how tether
has progressed and printed money after
being found to have lied to people
because the big question is is what are
they not telling us what are they
telling us so watch this watch this this
is tether's activity since the new york
attorney general determined they lied
this is the state of affairs
with crypto guys the people we think who
might be falsely inflating the market
this is where we knew they were lying to
us
this is now the state of affairs tether
is now worth more than bernie madoff's
ponzi scheme at its height tether is now
worth 72
billion and they've gone completely mad
with how much they're printing and again
we know this is not usd backed tether
themselves will tell you that they're
backed mostly by commercial paper ask
them who
who's who's commercial paper do you hold
they won't tell you in fact they'll
block your foia request to find out as
uh we talked about in this video over
here i mean if you look at just even
just the past seven days you can see
that the printer rooney is going
crazy they're just printing the dollar-y
dudes dude look at this they went from
what like 70 billion market cap to a
72.5 that's 2.5 billion dollars in seven
days ladies and gentlemen let's give it
up for them dude cryptos becoming what
they sought to fight with fiat like fiat
everybody thought oh that's clearly you
know a scam the way they're printing
money over there inflation's gonna kill
us all and then you go over to crypto
you think you've diversified tether
until there's printing together the
central bank is sprinting it almost as
fast as jay powell quite wild quite
insane and if you're watching the
markets you're just concerned about
hedging your risk just bear in mind this
no pun intended uh when thinking about
your crypto investments it's fine to be
bullish on the technology of crypto i
also am too
but you have to be smart about it guys
you have to know that there are a lot of
grifters a lot of scammers in this game
and this stuff is linked to all sorts of
things like bitcoin ethereum price like
i don't know so
whatever happens when it all comes
crashing down i'm i'm pretty well
convinced that something bad is going to
eventually happen with tether when it
does what exactly happens is anyone's
guess i don't think the market's gonna
go to zero uh i've never said that but i
do um worry that people may under
underestimate
what this is actually going to do so
guys just keep that in mind when you are
um out there trying to trying to invest
in the market but anyway guys that's
just what i wanted to show you um we
knew they were lying here this is what's
happened since do with that what you
will thanks for watching i'll see you in
the next one
[Music]
but things will be different if i was
balling